[Musik]
ich bin namen ich bin militärpolizist
und militär streifen soll dann als
militärpolizist bezeichnet man uns im
ausland und das militär soldat
bezeichnet man uns im inland im ausland
übernehmen wir durchgehend polizeiliche
aufgaben und im inland wie die polizei
so zu sagen fürs bundeswehr
[Musik]
eines unserer hauptaugenmerke im ausland
ist speziell zugriff das ist irgendwie
auch auf
also ich kenne mich streifen soldatin
bei der ersten kompanie streifen an dem
in wien genauso wie ordnungsdienst
sicherheitsdienste und dergleichen sind
dann wären ein großer teil unseres
aufgabengebietes und gehören zum
typischen boot
verletzungen geht hauptsächlich darum
dass über schwere
sportlich mögen es ungehindert im
verkehr bewegen kann und dass alle
anderen verkehrsteilnehmer nicht
gefährdet werden und auch nicht geführt
werden
[Musik]
ich bin nicht vom spezialversand
militärstreife militärpolizei und bin
dort um personenschutz stimmt für uns
unterscheidet man zwei übungsphasen der
eine übungsphase ist zum beispiel hier
in der maria theresien kaserne
wir üben zum beispiel das richtige aus
und einsteigen das gehen in der
formation mit der schutz person so wie
zum beispiel das evakuieren der schutz
personen fahrzeug
[Musik]
die arme phasen sind draußen in der
stadt dort wo wir direkt unter den
menschen auch arbeiten müssen
[Musik]